we are asked what number set does the
number eight belong to so this is
actually a good review of the different
sets of numbers that we often talk about
so the first set under consideration is
the natural numbers natural numbers and
these are essentially the counting
numbers and you're not and not counting
zero so just if you were actually to
count objects and you have at least one
of them we're talking about the natural
number so that would be 1 2 3 so on and
so forth
so clearly 8 is a natural number you can
count up to 8 here you could count 8
objects so 8 is a member of the natural
numbers so it is a member of it is a
natural number we should say the next
one we should consider let's consider
the whole numbers whole whole whole
numbers right over here and I should say
natural numbers natural numbers so let's
consider the whole numbers the whole
numbers are essentially the same thing
as the Rasch as the natural numbers but
we're now going to include 0 so this is
0 1 2 3 so on and so forth so clearly 8
is one of these as well you could
eventually increment your way to 8 like
you're just counting all of the whole
numbers another way to view this is the
non-negative numbers so 8 clearly
belongs to this as well so let's expand
our set a little bit let's think about
integers let's think about the set of
integers now these are all the numbers
starting with what you could keep
counting down but all the way up to
negative 3 negative 2 negative 1 0 1 2 3
and you could just keep going there now
clearly 8 is one of these as well you
could just keep counting today in fact
you can let me just put our check box
there in general you have your integers
that contain both the positive and the
negative numbers and a zero depending on
whether you consider that positive or
negative or neither so that's the
integers right over here this is the
integers and then the whole numbers is a
subset of the integers the whole number
is the whole numbers are a subset of the
integers
so I'll draw it like this the whole
numbers are right over here that is the
whole numbers
we've now excluded all of the negative
numbers so these are all the
non-negative numbers all the
non-negative integers I should say so
these are the whole numbers and then the
natural numbers are a subset of that the
natural numbers are a subset of that
it's essentially everything so the only
thing that's in whole numbers that's not
in the natural numbers is just the
number zero so this is this whole area
right here just corresponds to the
number zero so it really should be a bit
of a point so let me make it clear let
me make it clear this that is though
this circle is the whole numbers and
then I have the natural numbers which is
a subset of that now obviously this
isn't drawn to scale the natural numbers
of a subset of that eight is a member of
all of them eight is sitting right over
here so it's a member of the natural
numbers the whole numbers and the
integer so let's keep expanding things
let's talk about rational let's talk
about rational numbers rational rational
numbers now these are numbers that can
be expressed in the form P over Q where
both P and Q are integers so can eight
we express this way well you can express
eight you can express eight as you can
express 8 as 8 over 1 or actually 16
over 2 or you could just keep going 32
over 4 you can express it as a bunch of
a bunch of P's over Q's where both the P
and the Q are integers so it's
definitely a rational number and in fact
all of these things over here are
rational numbers so let me draw so this
is all a subset this is all a subset of
rational numbers so 8 is definitely a
member of that as well rational numbers
so let me put the check box over here
now what about irrational numbers
irrational irrational numbers well by
definition these are numbers that are
not rational these are numbers that
cannot be expressed in this form where P
and Q are integers so something is
rational it just cannot be irrational so
8 is not a member of the irrational
numbers the irrational numbers are
completely separate set over here so I
would draw it like this this area right
over here this would be the irrational
numbers irrational rational is not a
subset of irrational it's a they'd
they're they're exclusive you can't be
in both sets so that's irrational right
over there and then finally let's ask is
eight a member of the real the real
numbers now the real numbers are
essentially all of these is combining
both the rational and the irrational so
the real numbers is all of this all of
this right over here and so eight is
clearly is clearly a member of the real
it's a member of the real and within the
real you're either can be rational or
irrational eight is rational it's an
integer it's a whole number and it is a
natural number so it's definitely a
member of the reals and just to give you
you might be saying hey well what is an
irrational number then can't almost
every number be represented like this or
every number can you you could think of
it can be represent like this and an
example of an era of maybe the most
extremist example of an irrational
number is pi
pi is equal to 3.14159 and their whole
you know people devote their lives to
memorizing the digits of pi but what
makes this irrational is you can't
represent it as a as a for as a ratio or
as a rational expression of integers the
way you can for rational numbers and
this right here is non repeating non
repeating and if it was repeating you
actually could express it as the ratio
of integers and we do that in other
videos it is non repeating and non
terminating non terminating so you never
run out of you never run out of digits
we work to the right of the decimal
point so this would be the example of a
rational number so pi would sit here in
the Irrational's anyway hopefully you
found that helpful